on va encore parler de sport à présent
on va parler de baseball puisque du côté
de Montini le Bretonneux les play-offs
de 2e division se poursuivent ce premier
dimanche de septembre a débuté par une
confrontation face à Montpellier deux
victoires à l'arrivée vous envoyez les
images 8 à 2 puis 11 à 6 excellente
opération après un succès obtenu juste
avant les vacances face à chartre trois
victoires une seule défaite depuis le
début de cette phase finale l'équipe
évelinoise peut toujours espérer gagner
le titre et pourquoi pas regagner sa
place en élite la plus haute division
cependant même si les joueurs sont
motivés il faudra tout de même que les
dirigeants du club acceptent de monter
ils préfèrent réfléchir à la solidité de
leur projet mais également réfléchir à
l'engagement voir si les joueurs sont
suffisamment motivés on va écouter
arnaaufo l'entraîneur de cette équipe de
2e division de Montini le Bretonneux en
baseball ce sont que des joueurs de
Montini
c'est la plupart sont des joueurs de
l'équipe une donc de l'année dernière et
des joueurs de l'équipe 2 qui sont
maintenant donc dans l'effectif premier
et c'est non non on a les mêmes joueurs
et l'objectif c'est ça donc c'est pour
ça l'année prochaine on veut être sûr
que tous ces joueurs de Montini peuvent
continuer à s'engager sur une saison en
élite sachant que c'est plus c'est plus
d'entraînement c'est plus de déplacement
ça va coûter plus d'argent au club et
voir si éventuellement on se renforce si
on a l'argent pour se renforcer on verra
mais ils sont les joueurs de Montini
donc desésign Montin c'est ce qu'on
voulait et côté agenda en sport reprise
de saison pour les féminines de Montini
le Bretonneux toujours en ligne la
première division nouvel entraîneur qui
vient de prendre les reennes de l'équipe
va-t-il trouver la bonne méthode verdict
du terrain le 9 septembre à 15h à
domicile et puis eux aussi ont raté la
montée l'équipe senior homme de Guy
encour toujours du football mais homme
cette fois-ci pour accéder à la DHR ils
doivent en ouverture de saison s'imposer
directement pour marquer un petit peu le
terrain face à saintmort 9 septembre
coup d'envoie également à 15h du côté de
guyancour nous allons arriver dans les
20 dernières minutes de cette émission
on va parler économie à présent